now to the extreme weather on the west
coast it has killed at least five people
cell phone video captured a rare tornado
just east of downtown Los Angeles
tearing roofs off the buildings and
sending debris flying through the air
very scary stuff Janet shamly in reports
from Montebello where that tornado
struck
cell phone videos captured a tornado
ripping the roof from a Los Angeles area
building oh my God
scared gusting winds sent debris flying
almost a dozen other buildings were
damaged a bunch of wind a crazy wind and
uh just everything Flannery were it
picked us up and threw us against the
fence as we were trying to get inside
for a shelter take a look at all this
Damage Done in an industrial sector of
Montebello by a tornado of all things at
least one person was taken to the
hospital hit by that flying debris a
similar scene near Santa Barbara Tuesday
evening when a tornado tore through a
mobile home park one person was hurt
more than two dozen of the homes were
damaged
in the San Francisco Bay Area the storm
is responsible for five deaths after
Hurricane force winds toppled trees and
plunged thousands into the dark the
winter storm shattered daily rainfall
records in several California cities as
communities dealt once again with the
impact of that rain including landslides
in the Central Valley 24 000 homes and
buildings are at risk of flooding from
the nearby swollen River and Lake in
Tulare County some 800 homes have
already been damaged some destroyed we
were not prepared we do not have fun
Assurance we already got our denial
letter when we did buy this house it was
not a pleasant so we didn't we didn't
think we needed it
tornadoes are rare in this region this
one caught many people off guard there
were no tornado warnings in place here
in Montebello when that storm hit
yesterday Tony California is really
getting it Janet thank you very much